we have a poll here from Gallup which
actually shows belief in five
Supernatural entities edges down to new
lows well first they don't even like
that framing Supernatural entities uh
they're talking about God angels heaven
uh they bleep out the censor out the
word hell
um and also the devil yes so so belief
in God has etched downward you you see
this the trend over the past 20 years or
so it was interesting because as I was
reading this article one thing that
really uh was depressing to me was the
fact that they were listing the
discrepancy between Catholics and
Protestants and the number of Catholics
and Protestants who believe in God why
would it not be 100 for both groups
but you can identify this time but there
is a cultural element to Christianity
especially people who say oh I would I
was always Protestant but I actually do
nothing about it I don't read the Bible
I go to church when I'm made to go to
church they don't live it but they will
claim the identity I think that can be
attributed to a little bit of this I
think it parallels the decline in people
that uh feel patriotic and feel feel
proud of America absolutely and if you
look at the trend lines that they
parallel and and father carelessness too
because I you know there there's a
reason he is described as God the Father
uh there are many reasons for it but a
person's relationship with their father
is going to inform their attitudes
towards God very heavily in fact
statistically we know one of the number
one predictors of a child choosing to
stay with their religion other family is
whether their dad practices that faith
if the mom practices that Faith they're
likely to some degree to stay in but not
nearly as likely as if their dad
practices the faith it's incredibly
important kids learn about God by the
way that their fathers act and it's
something that we don't really account
for or consider God and how to live I
mean exactly and learn all sorts of
things to their parents and the the
decisions that you make in your life and
when you because become a parent should
be cognitive the fact that someone is
now watching you someone is looking up
to you and I think so much of our
anti-responsibility culture parallels
this right like I don't want to think
about God because I don't want to think
about the afterlife because I don't want
to have to think about the fact that my
decisions have consequences in 30 years
of being on radio I've invited Jesse
Jackson on dozens of times he won't even
respond I'm invited Al sharpen on dozens
of times won't respond uh Maxine Waters
won't respond uh Louis Farrakhan
wouldn't respond but one of these
so-called black leaders um fume at the
time he was head of the NAACP president
he was in Congress in Maryland now he's
back in Congress in Maryland and he did
come on the show and my first question
was as follow Mr mfume as between the
presence of white racism or the absence
of black fathers which poses a bigger
threat to the black community without
missing a beat to his credit he said the
absence of black father good for him
yeah yeah I mean it's undeniable and
you're right it is to his credit because
the entire left-wing establishment is
going to punish anyone who says
something like that but it's just so
undeniably true I was just wondering if
I could ask you're listing this uh this
band of people who don't want to speak
to you presumably because your
conservative or republican uh can you
tell us a little about how about how you
got to this this place politically
I mean how I became conservative yeah
when did you adopt the title a
republican uh well I my mom was a
Democrat my dad was a Republican and
they would have these very interesting
uh disputes across the dinner table
nobody called anybody a fascist nobody
called anybody a Nazi nobody said you
only care about the the rich you don't
care about the poor and so as a kid you
identify with your mom and so I was a
democrat in fact the first person I
voted for for president was Jimmy Carter
and that was because he uh uh uh forward
pardon Nixon and I thought that was
inappropriate I now think it was a smart
thing to do and so I punished uh him for
doing that and so I voted for Jimmy
Carter but from that point on I voted
Republican you punished the American
people if you held Carter get elected I
was an independent for years and then I
decided to run uh against uh Barbara
Boxer I forget the year but a bunch of
people prevailed upon me to do that and
so I switched my affiliation from
independent to Republican and then I
flew to DC to interview with a bunch of
uh Republican Senators to see if I can
get the nomination get the endorsement
during the primary season if they had
endorsed me I was going to run they
endorsed Carly fiorina instead of me so
I decided not to run and by the way when
I found out that they endorsed her I
said why they said three reasons she's a
woman I said I'll give you that I'm not
gonna have a sex change operation to run
for Santa she has more money than you do
she did because she just uh resigned
from Hewlett-Packard they gave her a big
settlement the third reason was she has
higher name recognition than you do I
said no she doesn't maybe she does in DC
but not in California I had a 30 name
recognition her apartment Box's first
two opponents a guy named Bruce
Hutchinson and then a guy named Matt
Fong at the same juncture had a five
percent name recognition and Carly
fiorina lost by 10 points and put very
little by the way of her own money into
the campaign yeah uh long answer to your
question that's when I became a
registered Republican but I've always
been a small ill libertarian well I was
going to say if if you were identified
as a potential candidate to run for
office as a republican they must have
been aware that you were toying with
conservative ideas was that something
you got a lot of pushback for and uh did
you resist staying independent to resist
the label of Republican I think so
because I always feel both parties still
spend and I still do one of the things
I'm proposing is an amendment to the
Constitution to fix spending to a
certain percentage of the GDP that's
great with exceptions for war and for
natural disaster other than that they
both spend and um part of it is because
the so-called entitlements programs are
on automatic pilot uh Social Security
Medicare Medicaid Obamacare and a few
others and if you even suggest you're
going to reform them and try to run for
office you're going to lose well you
know so so the can gets kicked down the
road even Barack Obama and Bill Clinton
used the word unsustainable to describe
the entitlements program so everybody
knows that they're unsustainable you
just can't politically do anything they
don't want to ask them no and if but
however if you're forced to do it by law
then then and only then will there be a
reform for young people like you they're
not going to be there uh and so it seems
to me the president and I will do that
when I become president would use the
bully pulpit to explain this to people
particularly young voters that this is
in your best interest and maybe
something can happen and so what I just
want to ask quickly uh where would you
fix that uh GDP to Reverend
which is half of what uh it's it's it is
at right now all right it's going to
require massive massive changes yeah uh
and um I say 10 because in 1900 at all
three levels State local and federal
Believe It or Not government took nine
percent from the American people now all
three levels government takes 32 percent
and in my opinion if you put a cost to
the mandates government takes almost 50
percent yeah this is way way bigger than
what the founding fathers intended they
did not intend for there to be an income
tax they intended for The Limited duties
and obligations of the federal
government to be paid for by duties and
tariffs they would be appalled at
Obamacare they'd be appalled at Social
Security they'd be appalled at Medicare
they'd be appalled at FEMA they'd be
appalled at the things that the federal
government is doing well it's
interesting you point out that the
federal government takes so much of our
money and they have and you're right
there but there's a an interesting
observation this is referred to as
Hauser's law I'm not sure if you're
familiar with this but the basic idea is
that regardless of where tax rates are
regardless of how much the government
tries to take since World War II Federal
revenues have always hovered around 19.5
percent which just goes to show that if
you you impose these insanely high taxes
on people they either become less
productive and so there's less attacks
or they start hiding their money so the
government can't get to it rich people
are not rich because they're stupid yeah
that's right they hide their money or
they put them in other other kinds of
things so that they're taxed less yeah
and so you know there are certain
left-wing commentators who will scoff at
the idea of the Laffer Curve and a more
sophisticated left-wing approach is to
say okay the Laffer Curve exists but I
don't think the parabola Peaks until
we're at 70 percent in terms of our tax
rate all right well that's ridiculous
but at least you're acknowledging the
reality that if you tax people uh at
zero percent you'll have zero Revenue if
you text them at 100 you'll also have
zero Revenue because no one's going to
work and there's some point along the
Middle where you maximize uh revenue for
the government but it's also very
valuable for us to have this empirical
data that shows us you don't seem to be
able to get past 20 on the federal level
in terms of what you're taking in so why
aren't they adjusting the way they tax
us so that we can keep more of our money
since their revenue pretty much won't
shift from there that's a great point we
were talking earlier about the ignorance
between how many unarmed black men are
killed versus what people think same
thing with taxes I was at a party a few
years ago a buddy of mine was
celebrating his birthday he's a Vietnam
vet I assumed everybody at the party was
conservative thinking like I think it's
a woman and she started complaining she
started complaining tell me about it
it's always somebody uh she was
complaining about how rich people didn't
pay very much in taxes I thought she was
joking At first she kept saying it over
and over again I said excuse me I
overheard you say rich people don't pay
their taxes I said I'm probably one of
the so-called Rich if you find somebody
making above 350 000 or more as in the
top one percent
all right so I have my 1040 in the car
would you like to see it she said no I
said of all the federal taxes what
percentage do you think it's paid by the
rich he said what do you mean I said
soon this pie is all the federal taxes
what slice by percentage is paid by the
top one percent oh I see what you mean
one percent
she said maybe two percent oh my gosh
and and Shameless I kept waiting for her
to ask me what the answer was because he
saw my face I looked appalled like you
did and she never asked she didn't want
to know and the numbers the number is 40
yeah well while taking in 15 to 20 of
the nation's income so if anything rich
people are over taxed not under under
taxed she doesn't want to hear that no
when you look at income tax I think it's
what the top 10 pays 90 percent of the
income tax and it's insane and the
bottom 50 pay by four percent they pay
almost nothing and then the best part of
that story is that you were driving
around yeah
this kind of complaints like when can I
I'm in California when you put in the
state income tax uh sales tax property
taxes it is not uncommon for somebody
with regular income as opposed to
capital gains income being taxed at 60
yeah even Bill Moore complained about it
one time and this is part of lost Bill
Maher then you're then you're probably
over taxing people and as someone who
runs a business myself when you have to
cut that money out of your own bank
account rather than having your employer
withhold it from you you start seeing
taxes in a little bit of a different way
this is one of these reforms that I know
there are probably implications to this
that I'm not really really exploring by
so haphazardly suggesting we do this but
I'm often tempted to say we should make
every American person pay their taxes
that way no one should have their taxes
upheld by their employer you should have
to pay it in a lump sum so that you see
what they're taking for you I heard
Milton Friedman say it was a huge
mistake that we have automatic
withholding like the people really saw
what they were what they were being
charged for taxes we would have changes
yeah absolutely I think that's true I
think that's one of the problems some of
our systems uh insulate people or they
keep people from the realities of what
they do I say I I this is one of my
favorite tangents of all time but I
really think that we need to breed a
culture of responsibility and long-term
thinking I think there are reasons why
this this tax withholding is it seems
nice and somebody else deals with it but
ultimately you vote very differently
when you're well informed this is a
theme we keep coming back tonight when
when you're talking to this woman at a
dinner party and she says I don't want
to know it's because that way she
doesn't have to change her opinion she
doesn't have to evolve her world view
based on accurate information and being
well informed brings us to the disaster
that we call public education in the
inner city 13 public high schools zero
percent of the kids can do math a grade
level zero another half a dozen were six
percent can excuse me another half dozen
one percent can because half of all the
public high schools in Baltimore all
located in the inner city we the kids
are one percent or zero percent math
proficient it's Chicago 53 schools zero
percent are mass proficient if you can't
and 85 percent of blacks uh in the
eighth grade these are 13 year old kids
can either do math nor read a grade
level and half of them can't do basic
reading which means you cannot
critically think yeah and you can be
manipulated by emotion so scary it is
scary I'll mention this my father was a
public school teacher on the south side
of Chicago and for his entire career he
taught and then towards the end of his
career he became a vice principal and
then eventually principal and one thing
he would talk about was the fact that
when they as the high school would get
these students from their middle schools
they were so unbelievably far behind
that the best they could hope to get
them to do was still significantly below
where they should be it's it's a very
sad State of Affairs
teaching to the curve yes and as a
result everybody else suffers that's
right why we've got to have vouchers
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time